[Music]
so remember last week when Hillary
Clinton smeared millions of women we do
not do well with white men and we don't
do well with married white women and
part of that is a an identification with
the Republican Party and a sort of
ongoing pressure to vote the way that
your husband your boss your son whoever
believes you should
oh those evil white men well instead of
letting things lie she took a front-end
loader and dug a hole so deep you could
fit all her husband's skeletons in it
after claiming women only do what
they're hubby's tell them to she said
she meant no disrespect meaning she's so
clueless she thought comments made in
India somehow wouldn't travel but she
also added this quote I did not realize
how hard it would hit many who heard it
so you see what she did there it's the
jab and hide of a typical bitter troll
you know who tweets hey you're fat
followed by wow I guess I struck a nerve
so when she calls women's submissive
morons their defiant response means oh
she has to be right now you could say
Greg you enjoy Hillary's decline too
much yes and you'd be right for I'm
thinking we dodged a bullet
every time she speaks she reminds you of
why she lost and what she thinks of you
but Hillary's rage is really just a
projection decades of doing her
husband's submissive bidding it didn't
pay off the world is an unjust place in
her vengeful state I deserve to be
President she thinks after enduring the
humiliations of bills betrayals one man
made her feel very small and she repays
that sentiment a million fold on the
female Trump voter many of whom voted
for Obama it's payback delivered to the
wrong people
so Dems what do you do with a guest who
will not leave thank god you're not
stuck with her I hear there's a bright
young face on the horizon
in 2016 it wasn't their year but in 2020
the Democrats will unleash a brand-new
candidate to lead the resistance to
victory someone with a new vision for
America a freedom fighter a fresh face a
grassroots hero her name Hillary Clinton
this up-and-comer is bitter mean cranky
and vindictive all the things you want
in a rising star in just four short
decades she's already given so much to
real Americans things like hugs faces
fashion and totally normal laughter plus
this long list of accomplishments Wow
so Pope Hillary Clinton in 2020 she's
new
but she'll grow on you so one you were
right I don't want her to go away I
can't live without Hillary that's why 20
Hillary 20 21 get on the bus is that it
yeah for you she wasn't elected she's
not present that's why most of America
is focused on oh my god you said we were
saved by her not being elected I don't I
think a lot of people think oh my god so
the chaos is okay but here's the thing
Hillary Clinton wasn't wrong Hillary
Clinton actually there studies that show
exactly what she said to be true but
like dick Durbin said guess what this
wasn't helpful because in fact it feeds
all of the right-wing grievant so
Hillary Clinton and then you had Kelly
Ann Connolly come on oh she's not a
feminist she doesn't believe in women
it's what is the case and what is proven
is that number shift and that women can
feel influenced by husbands but it's
also the case that women might agree
with their husbands yes and you know
what's funny it's a one-way street
Kimberly like if a woman could influence
her husband that's a good thing but if a
husband influences the wife bad thing
why isn't there some shared operation
norms of reciprocity some just like
equality communicating wise and
influence wise you know Hillary just
can't help herself she loves being
Hillary meaning she's very consistent in
terms of her messaging what she says and
I think she was being honest there so
I'm glad she was being transparent she
tells us exactly what she
Thanks so that's fine it's no problem
she wants to tell the American people
especially you know married women and
white men that she is disappointed in
their choices all right you know well
they can make choices based on your
information that you're giving and
putting out there and it's not helping
the party that's why they're glad to
retire her you know Danny that one thing
she did you see all the time where
somebody will insult you and then when
you go wait a sec what are you talking
to oh sorry you felt that way yes nerve
yes that's the worst way to argue with
the spouse to by the way yeah the other
thing is that she refuses to talk about
policy like the policy choices are
actually preferable for Republican women
prefer to vote for Republicans
regardless of who it is the other thing
is is that Josh Hawley who is the
candidate running against Claire
McCaskill he has just cut an ad using
all of this stuff from Hillary yeah and
it's pretty effective so now they can go
after Pelosi and Hillary you know Jesse
the irony is she did just about
everything bill told her to do not
everything I think that happened here is
it was the typical politician apology
I'm sorry that you misunderstood me you
idiot that's the kind of apology that
she made and she only apologized because
people like Durbin criticized her for it
she wouldn't have said anything if no
one had you know raised that issue on
the right but it was just because the
people on the left in it she had to say
it I don't think she should have
apologized at all I agree with Kimberly
it shows weakness if she's shooting from
the hip and she's being real authentic
Hillary let it rip Hillary you know why
the book you know you said everything
you happen to say in the book go to
India you know make it rain with the
money just sing it I don't care that's
what you really think I know it's what
she really thinks we like authentic
Hillary even if it's authentically
pathetic the Facebook apology was
terrible it was about 16 paragraphs
that's not how you apologize you
especially don't do it on Facebook